the big news of the ballpark here today
is the fact that red's first baseman
joey votto
is not here at the ballpark as a
precaution he decided to stay home after
waking up this morning
with some symptoms the scheduled
doubleheader today
is going to be a major league first two
seven inning games but ronnie garcia
gets to start for the tigers in game one
that'll bring up nick casiano's hit the
pitch and castianos rips this one
high in the air deep left center field
that's way back there
and it is gone a two-run home run for
nick castellanos and the reds are on top
two nothing it's gotta feel good going
back to detroit and pulling that rabbit
out of the hat
no question anthony diesclefani makes
his 2020 debut today he was
9-9 last season with a 3.89 era
that brings up jonathan scope and diesel
funny delivers scope
sends one in the air right center field
on the run since a running catch
reaching out in the right center field
alley
to make the play nice running catch by
cinderella
senzel swung the bad well on friday had
a
double and a run scored he has been a
welcome addition back in the
lineup roll mine's setting up away 3-2
line drive left field coming in
reaching down sliding and making the
catch kristen stewart
shoguakiyama at the plate 2-2 swinging
to miss riding fastball up and away in
garcia
strains two castianos will be the first
batter as we begin
this third inning of play fastball
lifted high into the air into right
field
going back reyes looks up has he done it
again you better believe it two home
runs and two at bats for nick castianos
welcome back to detroit young man three
to nothing reds
doubling his home run total for the
season his first two at bats giving him
four on the year and
you know that's one of the things you
really like about castiano and it'll be
jamerr candelario austin romine and
jacoby jones seven eight and nine
here against diesel cophani chamber
candelario grounds one fair down the
first base line that's heading
into the corner chased down by
castillanos candelario around
second heading toward third put on the
brakes for a moment relay from the
outfield not in time man a one-hopped
strike from galvez to suarez at third it
looked like a little hesitation
for candelario around second but he
makes it to third a lead off triple here
in the third
and now that leaves it up to nico
goodwin three-nothing reds are in the
bottom of the third
three-nothing reds and d scaffany trying
to keep it that way the pitch
strike three called fastball right over
the inside corner
and goodrum takes it after being ahead
three-and-oh nice job of pitching by d
stefani here is cj crone
he lined out the second baseman
mustaches his first time up today
the 1-1 line drive deep down the left
field line hooking by the foul pole and
go on the home run had to wait for david
reckley the third base umpire
to make the call it was hooking the reds
may ask for a review
right now with cj krohn's third home run
of the year
tigers are on the board trailing 3-1 and
here we're gonna get a look at it
and that's a foul ball they're not even
gonna review it
we've gotten together they've decided
foul ball
the one-two pitch and it's a ground ball
rolled to the left side
galvest gloves throws in time and the
inning is over
tigers down in order again three-nothing
ball game
and castiano steps in for his third
at-bat
tyler alexander has struck out the first
eight batters he has faced
he's got a two-strike count on nick
castellanos
alexander setz
the two-two swing in a mess he
got him on strike my goodness nine in a
row and even tyler alexander can't hide
the smile on his face
as he ties the american league record
for consecutive strikeouts
nine in a row for tyler alexander
well leave it up to jacoby jones d
stefani
back to the plate fastball jam shot pop
up right side here comes castellanos
he's got it
and the inning is over we'll also bring
up a eugenio suarez
with one on and nobody out the one two
swing and a miss ten consecutive outs
recorded on strikeouts and josh van
meter at the plate
right handed pitcher fullmer the pitch
swinging a miss he got him with a
terrific changer
and the bases are now loaded for victor
reyes
the old ones swinging a high fly ball
right field
castillanos chasing it deep to right
center still going and he won't make the
play
it's off his glove against the wall and
straight away center
that's going to clear the bases all the
way to third goes reyes
as lugo crone and demerits score
and we're tied at three potential go
ahead run
at third jammer candelario has been
swinging early in the count at the plate
again the payoff swinging a pop-up
shallow left out goes suarez but it's
akiyama to make the catch the left
fielder puts it away
yamazou for two two strikeouts and a
walk right-hander jimenez sets the pitch
and akiyama grounds it right side and
it'll get through for a base hit
galvez will score barnharts into second
and the reds are back on top it's four
to three
how farmer will hit for the first time
now the 2-1
high pop-up left field not deep
reyes comes in he's under it and he
makes the catch for the third out
jacoby's up for two today
first pitch slider ground ball right
side deflects off the first baseman
recovery
boy that deflected off of the first
baseman
to kyle farmer who picked it up through
and then iglesias had to dive toward
right field to take the throw and kept
his toe on the bag
what a play two gone nico goodroom will
be the hitter
iglesias winds the one-two pitch swing
and a miss he struck him out
that's it reds win it final score 4-3
they take down the tigers